♪ WHY CAN'T BE LIFE BE SIMPLE ♪
♪ 5, 4, 3, 2, 1 ♪
MAYBE THEY WOULDN'T BE SO
DEPRESSED IF THEY STARTED
LISTENING TO SOME LMFAO.
WIGGLE, WIGGLE, WIGGLE, WIGGLE
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING.
FILMING YOURSELF HOLDING UP
FLASH CARDS WHEN YOUR FEELINGS
GET HURT IS THE NEW TREND.
I HATE BULLIES ALMOST AS MUCH AS
I HATE WEB VIDEOS.
THEY SAY THAT BULLYING IS THE
HIGHEST FORM OF FLATTERY.
DON'T TAKE IT PERSONALLY.
THEY'RE PROBABLY JUST JEALOUS OF
YOUR VIRGINITY.
WE SHOULD THANK BULLIES.
WITHOUT THEM CONSTANTLY POINTING
OUT YOUR FLAWS, YOU'D HAVE NO
DESIRE TO ACHIEVE GREATNESS AND
THEN RUB IT IN THEIR FACE.
AND IF YOU'RE GETTING BULLIED
FOR BEING GAY, JUST REMEMBER
EVERY SINGLE SUCCESSFUL PERSON
IN HOLLYWOOD IS QUEER.
EVERY ONE.
IF THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU FEEL
BETTER, YOU KNOW WHAT REALLY
SHUTS UP A BULLY?
LEARNING HOW TO BUILD A PIPE
BOMB.
I GET BULLIED BY THOUSANDS OF
YOU ONLINE EVERY DAY.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS I CAN
TAKE IT, BECAUSE I KNOW HOW
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER MY LIFE IS
THAN ANY OF YOURS WILL EVER BE.
BUT IT STILL HURTS.
♪
TURNS OUT MY SITUATION IS EVEN
WORSE THAN I THOUGHT.
SINCE THAT VIDEO WAS SHOT, I
FOUND OUT THAT IT ACTUALLY COSTS
$1,200 A MONTH TO HEAT MY POOL.
SO THANK YOU FOR ALL OF YOUR